[Music]
and there's no audio we got to really
set up all of that so a while back I saw
a video on Instagram of the skywriting
on a one wheel on top of two cases of
beer just riding along and I thought you
know what I'm going to do that with
these peach box pin pineapple apple box
the trick is to land on it from up here
get a good reserve so you want me to not
to this video good Apple box is the
center break slash
you get all right this app is also
touching the wheel for me to fly
whatever oh the horse
the climax babies go to your death
[Music]
now thank you keep it off make sure it's
like right on the center between the two
pubs I should be wearing a helmet
so jum Ren are you afraid
yeah I'm significantly clear here let's
go to your death go to Oggy
you're doing it red what's so scary I
could feel how unstable that was
actually pretty legit I thought you're
gonna crack your head language so I go
to me I go to these motorcycle like
get-togethers and add all these things
there's always somebody that's doing
wheelies and it's kind of like that like
you're just watching the whole time and
they're doing a wheelie down the street
and then they land and you and you go
okay that was like that was actually
really cool but the whole time you're
just waiting for something to go
horribly wrong something really cool is
happening as you're watching this video
Carmichael and I are out in Salt Lake
City at Sundance Film Festival and we've
been asked to speak on a brand panel
we're going to be speaking in front of
some of the highest people at some very
very big corporations about
advertisements on YouTube there's going
to be people on that panel such as the
senior marketing director for a major
shoe company
the VP of branded entertainment from
major soda company and we're going to be
talking to them directly about the state
of advertisement on YouTube if you have
concerns problems or issues about
anything with the current state of
YouTube advertisement put a comment in
this video and I will read it directly
to the people who are responsible for
selling those ads I'll hear you typing
we can't as a channel let this
opportunity pass by without informing
you guys that this is happening people
are going to be out there and they're
going to say oh well there shouldn't be
ads on YouTube or oh I just use adblock
Pro or whatever but the fact of the
matter is is that YouTube would not
exist if it wasn't for advertisers that
is an absolute fact if you're not okay
with that then there's nothing that can
really be said to that but assuming that
you're like most other people you're
going to accept a certain level of
advertisement for the entertainment that
you get on this platform now let's do
that better pretty cool all right
[Music]
so here anytime I don't hear any typing
good all right look
okay a lot more stable pickle that's a
dollar Oh No so the weighted one what
works is that there's a sensor like a
pressure plate in the box to evenly
distribute it's actually activated so I
just put something thin underneath the
box that should work work
Rann that's a second dollar no okay
we're in that's a dollar will it shred
we are about to skate a hoverboard this
is going to work
[Music]
so heavy